we are told to write seven hundredths as
a fraction and a decimal why don't you
get some paper and a pencil out and see
if you can do that before we do it
together all right so let's do it first
as a fraction so what is going to be the
denominator of our fraction if they're
saying seven hundredths and the way I'm
saying it is a little bit of a hint
seven hundredths well I think you've got
the picture we're dealing with
hundredths so our denominator is going
to be one hundred and then how many
hundredths do we have well we have seven
of them I'll do that in a different
color just to be clear we have seven of
those hundredths so there you have it
seven hundredths
that's this expressed as a fraction
now what about as a decimal well we
could think about our decimal places if
let's say that this is the ones place
and I'm just putting a little blank here
so it's ones place and you have a
decimal right over here and then this
would be the tenths place and then this
would be the hundredths place
well we have we want to represent seven
hundredths so let me be clear this right
over here is ones
this is tenths and this is hundredths I
like say it's unusually fun to say that
hundredths all right one's tenths
hundredths so how many ones do we have
here well we have no ones we have zero
ones how many tens do we have here well
we have no tents how many hundreds do we
have well we have seven hundreds okay
now it's getting annoying we have seven
hundredths so you could write it that
way as well and if I wanted to just
write it a little bit cleaner I could
just write no ones no tents and seven
hundredths I said it the last time like
a like a normal person let's do another
example here where is told select the
written form of each number and so they
on the Left right over here you have
different representations here we have
things written as a decimal fraction
another decimal and then we want to say
hey which of these are represented in
were
or a combination of numbers and words up
here so pause this video and half ago at
this as well okay so this first number
right over here we have no ones and then
as we go one space to the right of the
decimal this is the tenths place and
it's clear we have four of those tenths
so this right over here is four tenths
so that is this choice right here so we
would I'll shade it in if you're doing
this on Khan Academy you would just
click there and it would fill in so what
about this one well this one we would
read you have four out of ten or four
tenths so this again would be four
tenths so we would shade that one in now
what's going on over here we have no
ones we have no tenths we have four
hundredths I said it again it's too much
fun so we have four hundredths so that's
this column so we would fill that one in
and we're done